I can tell that you guys have a good
time when you're together oh the
chemistry and just the excitement the
journey that you take us on on screen
was very exciting so good so thank you
for that I enjoy walking out of here
unless we work together how much do you
feel like you're just having this kind
of like pinch me moment though you have
landed yourselves in the DC Universe is
it kind of like a childhood dream come
true to be starring in a comic book film
hell yeah DC in the DC Universe oh yeah
and to be in it with a bunch of other
incredible women I mean I don't think I
ever imagined that because I never saw
that you know I've never seen that
before so it's pretty amazing to be a
part of something that's in this
universe but also totally new and
totally something we've all been longing
to see for so long yeah and the r-rated
action comic book movie girl game ladies
hell yeah I know and I was just chatting
with Margo about all of those things as
well and then not also not only led by a
female cast but you got female producers
in the mix you got a female screenwriter
you've got a female directors color yes
it's so good I love all those things all
right now what did you love most though
about your costumes
I left the the functionality of my know
your face and some not so much
not so much but you know our costume
designer Erin was amazing cuz we had to
do so much fighting in it yeah it was
like okay how do we make this practical
so she had to make like doubles and
stunt versions of the pants my pants
freaking suck to kick in let's just be
clear and I was like there's a story
here to these pants though you got to
give it just know I mean so she ended up
having like to build extra stretchy
stuff in the crowd like I got to get my
leg all the way up there and so but um
one of my favorite costumes is the
fishnet dress you know Black Canary is
known for fishness so Erin was we were
really trying to figure out what the the
stage persona of Black Canary was and
you know trying to draw inspiration from
the comics and just one day we after
trying on this thing she just pulled out
this material and started literally
building this fishnet dress on me and
him brought me so much joy cuz I like we
have to have fishnets and something and
somewhere like a bad memory jamming and
then Rosie your character has like an
evolution of her wardrobe or costly my
aunt is pretty drab find a you know drab
dark drab II colors that's so not you
girl it's so not me yeah I mean at the
very end she gets to have like a a live
leather jacket right but for the most
part it's like what is that I feel like
is it your character organ area that
says why does she always talk like she's
dead I thought I was coming about 80s
movie from like how she talks a little
bit how she dresses
yeah that's your character and it's yeah
she's she's you know she has other
things something we're a moral compass
and
at the center of this group and kind of
the compass for this girl gang of sorts
is Harlequin and Margot Robbie is taking
on that role what makes Margot a great
Harlequin
because she's an abandoned she's you
know you have to you have to not be
self-conscious and you have to allow
yourself just to go there and she does
that very easily and so I think that
that's the genius of her portrayal
Hollywood yeah she's so she commits and
she's so present in it and it's a very
spontaneous you know and that was what
was fun playing with her is you're
literally playing you know takes her
different you're improvising and you're
right in order to capture the essence of
Harley you have to have an actor who's
just willing to go there yeah especially
for a character like that because it's
her mind is in a million different
places at once you never know what's
gonna come out how she's gonna respond
how she's gonna walk I mean it's just
really fascinating to see I think Harley
Quinn is really like curious about
everything like her attention moves so
fast and and you know Margo is much more
focused and down-to-earth but she still
has that curiosity and that like joy
about everything so I think it's easy to
kind of you know slide it into Harley
Quinn because I'm Carly
who's having a good time and we also say
you know Harley's got this obviously
fierce female gang that she's got riding
with her right but she also has this
unusual sight of gravitating towards
really odd animals to have a sidekicks
as well from a hyena to a taxidermy
fever have you guys ever be friends it
or had as a pet I don't think I've had
as a pet but I did go I was in Tokyo
recently and I went to a pig cafe where
so you don't eat the pigs but just
cuddle with I've always wanted the tiny
pig for the tiny pig I just run around
you and I get in the lab and they fall
asleep in your lap like I had like three
pigs sleeping in her lap just like I
think we should take a trip to Tokyo oh
I'll take you there
[Laughter]
listen we're prop 9 you can't hold back
you gotta still build a team the same
and the same like makeup is this bizarre
no every bizarre we all mean Mary and
Margo were traveling and all had camel
colored coats and camel colored bags
it was Margo and I said last night birds
of a feather flock together a man and
hopefully all will flock together again
for a sequel be pretty cool yeah yeah I
mean look we are in love with our
characters I love black Canary so much
so
yeah awesome thanks ladies I appreciate
it
[Music]